ladies and gentlemen welcome to the atc
live show please welcome your host Bill
Bernal magical freak app so we got a
network we started this network in
October of 2013 and we serve a ten
podcast there's now 50 podcasts on the
network we decided that a new that she
in this business that people would try
to take this we actually when we first
started I don't even think we've told
the story but somebody from Texas came
in and they go they offered us 10% of
our own idea no [ __ ]
so we came up how do they think we're
gonna have them build a website for us
then they wanted to buy into it what
what the potential of this could be and
their first offer was they were gonna
own 90% of it and we were gonna own
sound like a good deal to me so there we
go back to the guy and we were like no
this is not how does that make any
[ __ ] sense and he goes okay 20% and
it got down to we still don't know but
he eventually offered us 50% and both of
us a hundred grand per year and we still
said no story I think now we have some
great podcasts I'm not sure if anybody
saw that Doug Stanhope just signed up
with this so you have Bert Kreischer
everybody that we that is great group
because me and Bill and and the network
is you know transparent numbers and we
also told people that we would our
relationships with them are more
important than the business we don't
care about the business we care about
going directly to you guys and a comedy
fans and sort of eliminating all of the
unnecessary [ __ ] about music [ __ ] so
this would be a slow build everybody
honest yeah which is it puts us here and
we appreciate all the support we are
actually it's this is on tube start we
is a have we have perks
for sort of helping out ATC in all
things comedy so you can actually go to
tube start in our campaign there and get
a bunch of [ __ ] in return you know
people were bidding on this stuff it's
being simulcast right now we're trying
to again not [ __ ] anybody over but now
we've taken on this whole public radio
sort of guys had to guess which one of
us is gonna crack first and just go
rogue it just becomes the exact [ __ ]
thing that we're fighting yeah I would
guess yeah like he looks like you know
the left turn in the movie like you
could put on a lab coat they look like
that yeah I know the honest scientists
without a one day takes those glasses on
yeah it's gonna [ __ ] happen you ran
away with all the money that's right I
tell you almost ran over somebody on a
bicycle today on a [ __ ] purpose
through the temptation